enfin on a une priorité aujourd'hui qui
est de ne pas laisser une forme
d'inversion des valeurs s'installer
quand on croit en septembre démocratique
et républicain
les meutres ne l'emportent pas sur les
représentants du peuple et la foule
quelle qu'elle soit n'a pas de
légitimité de ce peuple qui s'exprimer
souvent afin
d'interviews et les préciser regardez
somme une grande nation et un vieux
peuple il se dotent de responsable qui
ont une légitimité politique les
syndicats ont une légitimité quand ils
défilent qu'ils manifeste ils sont en
opposition à cette réforme quand des
groupes utilisent l'extrême violence
pour agresser des élus de la République
qu'il soit parlementaire aujourd'hui ou
mère parce qu'ils ne sont pas contents
de quelque chose alors là ça n'est plus
la République la démocratie
alors
là dessus comment vous l'avez trouvé
manuel Macron
j'ai trouvé très bon mais simplement une
précision sur l'audio que vous avez
passé qui est en fait quelque chose qui
a été enregistré hier dans une
conversation avec les députés avec les
parlementaires vous avez écrit les meute
j'ai entendu aujourd'hui tout au long de
la journée les syndicalistes dire on est
comparé à des chiens mais c'est pas les
meute c'est l'émeutes l apostrophe et ça
son importance parce que la nuance dans
le propos du président de la République
est importante donc ça il faut bien le
préciser parce qu'on est sur un terrain
sensible sur cette réforme et sur les
débats que nous avons on a eu un débat
hors plateau très pacifique on est en
train de se dire qu'en fait on va pas
s'attaquer mutuellement mais on va
essayer de trouver un terrain d'entente
parce que c'est très fort mais je crois
que le Président de la République c'est
pour ça que je l'ai trouvé bon a tenter
d'expliquer une nouvelle fois la réforme
parce que sans doute qu'il y a eu des
incompris sans doute qu'il y a eu un
moment donné des erreurs dans la
communication dans la manière dont on a
expliqué cette réforme et sans doute
aussi qu'il y a les instrumentalisation
de ce qui était proposé aux Français par
les oppositions qui certes en manque de
projet ne sont pas en manque d'idées et
de mensonge pour décrédibiliser l'action
du Président de la République cette
réforme elle est difficile elle peut ne
pas être acceptée on peut avoir des
désaccords et c'est ce que je dis je
voulais en venir à ce point-là sur le
président de la République c'est ce
qu'ils disent sur la différence entre la
foule et le peuple le peuple a tranché
plusieurs fois à des élections
présidentielle et les élections
législatives le cheminement démocratique
a eu lieu la foule ce n'est pas le
peuple le peuple légitimement faire
grève c'est constitutionnels peut
légitimement faire des manifestations ce
sera le cas demain mais ce n'est pas la
foule qui l'emportera sur le peuple Ludo
moi je pense que
l'intervention d'Emmanuel Macron
l'interview franchement la politique
j'en ai ras le bob ah pas mal il fallait
que je le place voilà bien fait et en
fait
dans tous dans tout votre discours qui
que ce soit ça manque de terrain
en fait parce que là vous n'êtes pas
dans la réalité vraiment je suis sincère
moi j'invite monsieur Macron comme je
depuis que je suis sur les plateaux je
l'invite à venir faire une immersion
même vous si vous voulez venez vous
allez voir comment c'est derrière un
camion ça pue ça pue la merde on ramasse
la merde les mecs ils sont crevés ils
ont mal au dos là les deux ans qu'on
prend dans la gueule ça fait mal
réellement
pardon pour les termes
c'est hyper compliqué alors moi je parle
de mon métier je parle en mon nom bien
évidemment mais il y a tout un tas de
métiers où c'est ultra compliqué je
reçois des messages partout des
infirmières des maçons c'est
impressionnant pourquoi on prend deux
ans dans la gueule vraiment on n'a pas
besoin de ça on arrive plus à moi par
exemple comment vous expliquer je
profite pas en fait je vais pas profiter
mais personne ne dit ça j'ai pas
64 ans vous imaginez
sur le papier on nous dit qu'on
partirait 57 59 sur le papier aux
ouvertures de droitier ensuite je fais
une catégorie ensuite 57 59 sur le
papier je dis bien mais en réalité on
part à 62 64 et pour mon cas je partirai
à 67 ans parce que j'ai une carrière
hachée steak haché à point je voulais
placer aussi merci
[Rires]
Emmanuel Macron il sait que cette
réforme est impopulaire il l'assume il
le rappelle pour lui ça aurait été plus
simple de ne pas la faire ce que
Géraldine maillet c'est vrai il a dit ce
que vous avez dit en fait c'est fou
au moment où je vous parle est-ce que
vous pensez que ça me fait plaisir de
faire cette réforme dites-le nous non je
vous le dis
je vous le dis en responsabilité moi je
ne cherche pas à être réélu je ne peux
pas constitutionnellement
mais entre les sondages et le court
terme et l'intérêt général du pays je
choisis l'intérêt général du pays et
s'il faut derrière endosser
l'impopularité aujourd'hui je n'en
danserai
est-ce que vous trouvez Géraldine que
Emmanuel Macron a calmé les choses ah
bah la macronie que je suis va être vous
dire qu'il a été excellent non non
franchement moi je m'attendais à rien
d'abord j'ai trouvé les interviews
catastrophiques très très mauvais ils
essayaient de se tirer
les deux je vais dire la vérité j'ai
rien contre puis je les aime bien mais
oui mais là il se tirait la beauté
de ce qui se passe dans la rue en fait
je comprends pas ils ont été très
mauvais et quand on leur a demandé
éventuellement quand il fallait être bon
ils ont pas été bon ils ont pas été au
rendez-vous quand par exemple Macron dit
oui mais on a discuté avec tous les
partenaires sociaux et que 10 minutes
après il y a Laurent Berger de la sfdt
qui dit bah non en fait on n'a jamais
discuté avec nous et donc c'est le 1/2
et un mensonge je trouve que là pour le
coup les journalistes n'ont pas fait
leur travail après pour le coup je
pensais pas qu'il allait dire en prenant
la parole je vais retirer la réforme
donc en fait rien n'a changé on a tenté
de conseil constitutionnel qui va
peut-être dire ben non finalement c'est
très fort mais elle est
anticonstitutionnel c'est encore un
espoir pour ceux qui sont dans la rue
après moi je pense j'y crois pas trop
après il a annoncé deux trucs sur le
travail et tout ça moi je pense que
voilà il faut il faut continuer on n'a
pas le choix et je comprends que ce soit
très dur pour pour les gens mais je
pense qu'il faut pas casser il faut pas
vandaliser et moi j'étais à peu près
d'accord avec tout ce qu'il a dit Gilles
Verdun vos amis de la France insoumoute
mes amis mais moi je l'ai trouvé
extrêmement terminé j'ai une question à
Loïc parce que à propos des débordements
on l'attendait beaucoup pour qu'il la
pèse il a dit donc une phrase qui
restera peut-être ni factieux ni faction
mais il a comparé aussi à ce qui s'est
passé aux États-Unis avec la prise du
Capitole et au Brésil avec les dires de
bolsonaro ce qui a beaucoup choqué
est-ce que vous pensez que ça ça va
apaiser ce qui se passe dans la rue je
sais pas si vous avez l'extrait en
question mais c'est pas une comparaison
c'est un risque que court chaque
démocratie aujourd'hui dans le monde
c'est à dire que qu'est-ce que un
factieux c'est quelqu'un qui sur l'ordre
d'un groupe va troubler l'ordre public
aujourd'hui et vous l'avez vu chaque
soir il n'y a pas des manifestants
contre la réforme des retraites qui
brûlent efficace ce sont des Black Blocs
ce sont un groupe ce sont des groupes
constitués parfois ils viennent de
l'étranger on le voit quand on arrive à
les interpeller ensuite vous avez des
députés et ça je ne sais pas si ce sont
vos amis Gilles Verdez de la France
insoumise qui pendant
ça me rassure pendant les débats sur la
réforme des retraites pas mes amis c'est
bon c'est important c'est pas le plus
important chacun pense qu'il veut et
chacun en démocratie pour savoir les
arguments qu'il veut à partir du moment
où on respecte l'ordre public et la
démocratie quand on voit un député de la
nation Thomas porte je le cite mais
écraser symboliquement la tête du
ministre du Travail et qui aujourd'hui
après avoir subi la plus grande peine à
l'Assemblée nationale revient et dit il
faut aller chercher le président et le
dégager de l'Élysée vous rendez compte
la responsabilité alors oui bien sûr ça
peut choquer quand on compare les 30
pistes les bolsonaristes à ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui dans les
manifestations mais on ne parle pas des
manifestants qui auront cours demain
dans les rues des manifestations qui
auront cours demain dans les rues on
parle des casseurs de ceux qui font des
blocages et de ceux qui menacent la
et demi de coup sur la riston de
carburant on a essayé et on tente chaque
jour de réduire l'inflation l'inflation
on en parlait énormément c'est en France
quelle est la mieux maîtrisée sur la
zone euro c'est quand même un effort de
finances publiques c'est pour ça qu'en
contrepartie on demande de faire des
efforts pour qu'à un moment donné chacun
puisse vivre de son travail ensuite
est-ce qu'il faut améliorer les choses
oui le président l'a dit pour la branche
inférieure en termes de salaire
c'est-à-dire les plus bas salaires il va
falloir trouver des solutions pour que
ces salaires augmentent il va y avoir
des concertations avec les partenaires
sociaux avec la CFDT avec la CGT pendant
la réforme des retraites j'ai
l'impression que personne ne le sait il
y a eu un accord entre les partenaires
sociaux les organisations patronales et
le gouvernement sur le partage de la
valeur c'est ce qu'a dit Emmanuel Macron
tout à l'heure quand vous avez des
entreprises qui rachètent leurs propres
actions à des coups de milliards
aujourd'hui ils doivent redistribuer aux
salariés et ça ça fait l'objet d'un
terrain d'entente entre la CGT la CFDT
le Medef et le gouvernement
je voudrais vous faire réagir sur un
truc là sur la Une de Charlie he qui est
sorti regarder peut-il rebondir Emmanuel
Macron avec voilà est-ce que vous dites
ça j'étais je suis je serai toujours
Charlie oui mais ça c'est des magots
ou pas déjà je vais vous dire un truc ça
me fait rien ah oui parce que Charline
fera toujours rien
excusez-moi
c'est une caricature si on est franchir
d'eau et moi j'ai toujours défendu
Charlie Hebdo et je suis très attaché à
la liberté de la presse et donc bah oui
je sais que vous n'êtes pas très fan de
Charlie Hebdo ben moi je le suis et je
le dis et c'est pas des magots ça vous
fait marrer
il faut
pas toujours ça ça vous fait rire
ça me fait en tout cas ça me choque pas
parce que c'est Charlie Hebdo et parce
qu'ils ont une liberté ce qui se passe
en ce moment vous trouvez pas que ça met
l'huile sur le feu
non parce que chacun aujourd'hui doit
prendre conscience que la liberté de la
presse la satire
à son humour et chacun réagit en
fonction je pense que vous ne faites pas
rire tout le monde bah oui pourtant vous
êtes à la télévision chaque soir
vous aimeriez qu'il est votre tête là à
la place monsieur Macron non je pense
que je n'aimerais pas et je pense que
voilà non je ne sais pas c'est terrible
le droit à la caricature
je serai toujours
des ma gauche sur un contrôle Loïc voilà
qui est très sympa d'être venu mais pour
moi ça c'est un discours d'une démagogie
extrême voilà
la liberté d'expression et il a dit un
truc aussi il est revenu sur les
manifestants qui se les manifestants qui
secouent la France depuis plusieurs
jours vous voulez d'abord assurer qu'il
l'entendait la colère mais condamne les
violences parce que vous avez dit à peu
près ici la colère s'exprime faut aussi
l'entendre et accélérer une démocratie
elle doit entendre la colère légitime
qui s'exprime dans un cadre républicain
et y apporter une réponse quand les
États-Unis d'Amérique ont vécu ce qu'ils
ont vécu au Capitole il faut dire on
respecte on écoute on essaie d'avancer
pour le pays mais on ne peut accepter
ni les faction ni les factions
pas et ça valait beaucoup plus loin
comme je le dis il faut pour mettre un
feu rouge il faut qu'il y a un mort
c'est fou quand même d'en arriver là
n'attendons pas pourquoi on ne peut pas
anticiper la France en anticipe jamais
là il y a possibilité d'anticiper
reculer pour mieux avancer monsieur
Macron allez-y mais vous voulez quoi une
réforme à 60 ans comme Monsieur
Mélenchon demande ou Marine Le Pen 60
ans aussi vous pensez que ça c'est la
solution
c'est magnifique avec ce métier vraiment
après ça dépend des métiers exactement
c'est compliqué les maçons c'est très
compliqué
les cheminots ils ont eu la retraite à
55 ans parce qu'il mourait à 45 tu vois
donc on leur a donné
55 mais il faut effectivement
vous savez bien vous avez bien vu que
c'était mort il reviendra pas en arrière
c'est terminé ça va être voté par le
Conseil constitutionnel
midi il a parlé de classement par toquer
ce midi il a parlé de classement à 55
ans mais vous voulez nous classer où il
y a pas de place
donc ça c'est du blabla en fait je suis
désolé mais c'est du blabla parce que
moi je répare classique moi je voudrais
dire sincèrement c'est que on parle de
la réforme des retraites j'espère que
tout le monde est conscient ici que ça
ne représente que 10% de la colère la
bien c'est général avec des Français
c'est-à-dire que
on s'en fout de ça et bien sûr mais la
France est en colère depuis très très
longtemps j'écoute la colère
c'est un héritage
il attend que ça explose exactement
exactement
auxquelles on assiste elles sont plutôt
bien tenues et ça on peut féliciter et
féliciter aussi l’inter syndicale qui
contrôle ces manifestations moi je fais
une différence entre ce qui va se passer
demain ce qui s'est passé depuis
plusieurs semaines avec ces
manifestations des syndicats et les
Black Blocs qu'on voit le soir et les
factieux dont parle le président de la
République qui n'ont que pour un seul
objectif mettre le désordre voir être
violent et notamment à l'égard des
forces de l'ordre qu'on aimerait tous je
pense ici saluer pour leur action c'est
un travail difficile ils ne sont pas
tous d'accord d'ailleurs avec la réforme
des retraites mais ils font le boulot
c'est à dire qu'il protège et il
maintiennent l'ordre public et on ne
peut que les saluer on les voit c'est
pas facile tous les soirs pour eux
ensuite sur ce que dit Monsieur Bigard
il a raison la colère elle est multiple
la colère elle est diffuse et la colère
elle est de longue date c'est un
héritage qu'il faut combler Emmanuel
Macron et là depuis six ans il l'a
rappelé je crois suffisamment de manière
claire tout à l'heure sur TF1 et France
2 On est passé de 9% de chômage en 2017
à 7%. c'est à dire qu'on va vers le
plein emploi si je peux juste terminer
moi j'ai toujours connu j'ai 34 ans le
chômage de masse on m'a toujours dit ne
quitte pas de CDI ne quitte pas ton
emploi tu ne retrouveras jamais essaye
déjà d'avoir un emploi François Hollande
le prédécesseur d'Emmanuel Macron n'a
pas pu se représenter l'élection
présidentielle pourquoi parce qu'il
n'avait pas réussi à réaliser sa
promesse d'inversion de la courbe du
chômage mais nous nous sommes en face de
le faire le chômage est donc plus
facilement
je suis d'accord avec vous
les salaires c'est important les
salaires exactement nous on gagne entre
1500 entre 1500 et 1700 €. alors
j'entends dire qu'on gagne 4000 €, c'est
n'importe quoi moi monsieur